il faut des couilles pour être capable de perdre et d'
échouer et de faire des erreurs aux
yeux du public comment vous obtenez votre vie plus comme
Nicki Minaj travaillez dur si vous voulez le faire
ce que je fais je travaille très très dur rester
à l'école non  abandonner
[Musique]
c'est comme si le rêve de toutes les petites filles
se réalisait, je veux dire, je ne pouvais pas savoir que je n'aurais jamais
imaginé que je ferais un spectacle
au milieu de Times Square et que ces
gens chanteraient toutes les paroles et
tout ça à  d'abord, je suis comme mmm
Kanye West Rihanna ou le petit Wayne je
suis qui nous a dit que quand ils ont sorti leur premier
album, personne ne vous connaît, donc les gens
s'attendent à ce que je vous fasse connaître Gio et
Sauveur, je pense que c'est un milliard de fois
mieux que  mon premier album et c'est juste
parce que je suis plus confiant et tu sais que
je ne l'ai pas vraiment fait j'ai juste foncé je
n'ai pas changé le je ne savais pas devenir
fou et nous faisons mes couplets un milliard de
fois j'étais juste  comme vous savez ce que
c'est qui je suis en ce moment, à prendre ou
à laisser,
je tiens à remercier toutes les personnes
dans le monde, mes fans m'ont donné
l'opportunité de faire tous les types de
musique et je m'attendais à être accepté par
différentes radios  stations et genres et
couleurs et tout le monde à travers l'arc-en-ciel
parce que c'est un peu comme un gros problème Je
[Music]
veux créer quelque chose que mes fans
peuvent porter et avoir l'impression que c'était une
représentation de moi même s'ils
ne pouvaient pas se permettre super super haut  haute
couture
[Musique]
quoi que vous fassiez ici continuez à le faire et
continuez à le tuer et vous savez merci
Dieu merci Dieu pour l'aide et la force vous
les gars nous sommes vivants aujourd'hui nous devons juste
être heureux pour cela
vous